[Musique]
nous nous sommes rendus compte qu'il y
avait en effet une augmentation
considérable du recours au cabinet de
conseil privé pour déterminer les
politiques de l'état on passe d'un
chiffre si on ne prend que les
prestations avec une composante
stratégique importante de 145 millions
d'euros en 2018 à 445 en 2021 par une
multiplication par 3 et puis si on prend
l'ensemble des prestations y compris
celles qui ont moins de caractère
stratégique on est au milliard d'euros
et probablement au delà puisque nous
n'avons pas
recenser toutes les agences opérateurs
de l'état on peut se demander si les
compétences existent au sein de la
fonction publique et notamment dans la
haute administration et ce qui est
interrogatif c'est quand même de se dire
qu'au préalable il n'y a pas
d'intervention auprès de ses
fonctionnaires pour savoir s'il ya
vraiment utilité du recours à ces
cabinets conseils on a des exemples où
les agents publics sont mécontentes de
ses interventions ils ont le sentiment
d'être infantilisés par ces cabinets
conseils et je pense que s'il y avait un
débat au préalable avec ces derniers
peut-être que les choses se passeraient
plus normalement qui décide dans cette
république évidemment tous les ministres
que nous avons auditionné dont nous ont
juré croix de bois croix de fer que
c'était eux qui prenait les décisions à
la fin sauf que c'est bien comment les
choses se passent quand on vous donne le
choix entre trois scénarios et que les
deux premiers sont impraticables
d'évidence vous choisissez le troisième
donc quelque part il peut y avoir ce
risque que des cabinets de conseil privé
au delà de leur travail d'éclairage qui
par ailleurs n'est pas remis en cause
amen le de la décision publique à se
faire de façon plus ou moins cachés il
faudrait interdire les est ce qu'on
appelle les pro bono c'est à dire les
interventions gratuites on dit toujours
que c'est le pied dans la porte pour des
cabinets conseils c'est à dire qu'il
rentre dans une administration et ils se
font reconnaître comme indispensable
pour mener à bien un certain nombre de
missions et après ils obtiennent un
certain nombre de marchés je pense qu'il
faudrait quand même faire l'état des
lieux des compétences dans les
administrations avant de faire appel à
des cabinets privés et puis la question
de la souveraineté de notre d'autres
pays c'est à dire que les cabinets ont
accès à un certain nombre de données
qu'en font-ils après on nous dit que bon
les données sont détruites mais est ce
qu'il y a des règles qui prévalent pour
effectivement ces données ne soient pas
conservées par ces cabinets mes soins
soient détruites donc un certain nombre
de mesures comme ça qui sont des
garde-fous si vous voulez pour que
l'intervention soit la plus minimale
possible et la plus exigeante possible
aussi